[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the guy who
doesn't know if Simon Fitz Fitz or Fitz
Fitzsimmons and we're already off to a
terrible start with the worst porn ever
anyway agents of shield is back for its
final season and throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down the
first episode there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the show yet then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the
video and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns on the season week by week
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our recap of
episode 1 okay so episode 1 takes place
in 1931 namely New York City as we know
from season 6 this is where the agents
ended up and I think judging by the
first entry this season is sort of going
to be a legends of tomorrow quest in
which the group must protect the time
liner or cost from the krona comms this
is very much set up in the introductory
scene in which we see three hunters
taking the faces of three policemen
shout out Slender Man we then get a
thirties inspired title sequence and I
really hope that they do this for every
era that the team go to because it looks
absolutely brilliant anyway aboard the
Zephyr we joined Simmons Mac and Daisy
who are pretty shocked to see Coulson
back once more we learn that Simmons was
able to resurrect him using chronic comm
hardware and the group's life model
decoy technology so else Coulson isn't
really the real real Coulson he's as
close as you can get humanly possible
anyway
well robot Li possible lmds have of
course been laced throughout the series
so far and whilst they've turned out to
be antagonists at several points Coulson
at least seems to be one of the good
guys now this kind of ties into my
theory on the whole L&D chronicon thing
I've actually thought that the LM DS
would actually be revealed to be the
precursors to the chronic comms and this
may be where the show is heading towards
with the use of time travel chronic
comms are an ancient synthetic that tend
to operate in a galaxy as observers
enoch stay that he was sent from 30,000
years ago to observe the people of earth
and it is possible that Coulson in some
ways may end up in the
passed and he may become the one that
kicked starts the race this could also
set up how Enoch was given the mission
to observe the agents of shield and a
lot more that theory is probably full of
holes but yeah I do think they're kind
of teasing at it here anyway Coulson was
built using the last available brain
scan on the character and he seems
pretty distressed to find out the
reality of the situation
it's very hard-hitting and he mentions
things like Ghost Rider
Tahiti which as we know is a magical
place the lighthouse and death of Fitz
this forces Mac to power him down and he
asks for the full one-one on well
whatever's going on through time streams
left by the tides of the chronicles
journey the group have been able to
follow the hunters as they attempt to
eliminate shield from history through
these tides Simmons has been able to
follow them and she shows the group the
new command center which is packed with
time specific weapons I spotted a tommy
gun m16 and some modern-day ones so I
think we might even stop by Vietnam
before heading home to the present let
me know below what times you think we
may see because I think these weapons do
sort of tease our all of the possible
periods we could get the team also meet
Enoch who talks like my grandma when she
wears headphones in case you don't know
Enoch is a chronic calm himself and he's
been scanning the airwaves for any sign
of the hunters everyone gets suited and
booted but the first thing that they
have to do is sort out Daisy's hair
purple in the past you damned SJW you
make me sick anyway we also learn the
fate of May and she's been recuperating
since coming back from isil's dimension
we'll get into what I think happened to
her more at the end of the video but she
gets fixed throughout the episode and
though we are told it should take a week
for her to recover it happens a lot
quicker we see a poster for Bela
Lugosi's Dracula and this could be a
nice little nod to hunters suck the life
out of their prey vampires are monsters
that appear as humans just like how the
chronic comes her synthetics that appear
as humans and in a way it's like poetry
they rhyme we also see a poster for the
Phantom of the West which was a 1931
film that followed a man that was
wrongly accused of murder he escaped
prison and found the true killer which
was a man that used their name the
phantom a phantom is often a term used
for someone who is able to create an
illusion of who they are
it's really hiding a dark nature to them
Hydra hid within shield like a phantom
the chronic comes our phantoms in some
ways as they've taken the identities of
policemen and there's a nice little
mirroring here of a Phantom Menace
because it's like poetry
they rhyme I feel sorry if you've just
started watching my channel and you
don't get that we do terrible jokes or
all of the time basically
anyway the set designers have really
created a living breathing the East New
York the last time we saw this in the
MCU was in agent Carter and also Captain
America the First Avenger and I would
love to have seen a young skinny Steve
or something but though we don't really
get a big easter egg it is still nice to
take at least a trip down memory lane
this is an era of prohibition and which
alcohol had to be sold on the black
market and this ties into one of the
main plot points in the entry dica
explains the timestream model which does
slightly contradict the multiverse one
from the main MCU I don't think they
care too much about trying to tie into
it anymore
but basically it means they should be
able to create minor ripples in the
timestream without causing any problems
the group hoses Canadian Mounted Police
and gain access to the crime scene after
daizy gives some stunning and brave sass
to a chauvinist man here Colson finds a
swordfish symbol which reminds him of a
New York City speakeasy that he heard
about in the SSR hero the password was
swordfish which he uses to gain entry
and they order drinks but the barman
pulls out a shotgun on them they're here
to meet someone called Gemini and this
is revealed to be Koenig who I'm sure
you recognize as Patton Oswalt Patton
has played the part of the Carnac
brothers throughout the series and this
is the sixth time that he's played a
relative of the family I loved seeing
him pop up and it was one of the biggest
surprises in the episode Gemini of
course symbolizes twins and the
colleagues at one point we're thought to
be twins so yeah this is a nice little
Easter Egg that ties into the overall
show at the crime scene deke manages to
digitally rebuild the faces of the
victims and he discovers what they look
like one of the chronic home cops
tells the guard at the door that if he
wishes to live but then not to come in
and the cop just lets him by because
this is the worst policeman ever just
lets any old straggler in with a bad
from a cereal box
you suck deke and Daisy battle it
with the two Crona coms and they managed
to steal a car and flee to the Zephyr on
board yo-yos diseases slowly starting to
disappear and she is also offered
synthetic arms that will allow her to
feel once more she initially turns him
down but does take them
finally meaning that she'll be able to
travel outside of the craft and interact
with missions at the speakeasy within
that Koenig is supplying alcohol for a
party in which New York Governor
Franklin Roosevelt will be in attendance
at FDR of course ended up going on to
become the president and he formed
shield
he was also mentioned in Captain
America's Civil War during the pen scene
in which we learned that the real-life
figure was also instrumental to the
creation of Captain America in real life
FDR was enabled to walk properly because
of polio and now he should have been
confined to a wheelchair the president
hid his disability by having AIDS helped
him to walk and also by using braces and
a cane he made sure to never be seen in
his chair as he thought it would show
him this week and during speeches his
sons would stand by to make sure he
didn't fall we see this play out in the
episode and it's nice that they paid
this much attention to detail with it
the chronic calm is seemingly you want
to assassinate the president before he
can even get the job so protecting him
is of the utmost importance the group
assembles at the party while Simmons
attempts to attain data on the chronic
calms plans from a hostage they flood
his bandwidth with nonsense data in
order to get him to spew out random bits
of information similar to how Coulson
did in the opening it's a nice scene
that works alongside the party where we
discover what's actually going on Daisy
has a heart-to-heart with Coulson and
it's kind of crazy to think about the
journey that they've been on throughout
the entire show I think their
relationship they're not often commented
on is sort of a surrogate father and
daughter situation and this has really
been the driving part of the series as
FDR goes to leave they assume that this
is when the hit will be carried out but
nothing happens it's actually revealed
that one of the bartenders Freddie who
worked for Koenig was the target all
along the Chronicles face melts and we
see a mysterious woman states that she
is his contact and that she has a job
for him Freddie must deliver a set of
vials that contain the future and that
in doing so his family glory will be
restored the woman is killed and it's
revealed that Freddie is actually the
father of Gideon Malick
eventually ends up becoming the leader
of Hydra Gideon was played by powers
Boothe and you might remember that he
featured in the Avengers movie and also
throughout season 3 of agents of shield
so the chronic comms actually wish to
take out shield by eliminating the need
for it if they destroy Hydra then shield
will never need to be formed and it's a
nice little twist on the whole
time-travel thing aboard the ship
Enoch realizes that may has escaped the
healing chamber and she lingers above
the room looking like something from
hereditary now what is going on with the
scene and exactly what's up with me well
the last time we saw her she'd just
gotten back from eyes else dimension I
actually have a theory that she was
possessed by something from that and she
may even end up becoming the big bad of
the season whilst time-traveling they
need a unifying threat in the show that
comes across all of the decades so it is
possible that this may come in the form
of May it was said that she would take
weeks to heal by Simmons but here she's
hopping around so it seems like
something far more sinister is going on
I think would really add an interesting
dynamic to the show if she was playing a
more villainous role and this could be a
flip on season 6 in which they were
trying to save Coulson this may well
turn out to be untrue buh when we know
eyes'll carries the ability to possess
people anything is possible
now obviously I loved hear your thoughts
on the first episode so make sure you
comment below and let me know if you
enjoy this video then please drop a
thumbs up and make sure you check out a
breakdown of some of the insane details
and the Iron Man series which is gonna
be linked at the end we've gone over the
whole trilogy movie by movie so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat juice after
the show either follow us at heavies
spoilers or click the discord link in
description below every month we give
away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this month
he can win the Marvel phase 3 part 2 box
set and all you have to do is comment on
a video and make sure you serve with
notifications on the more videos you
comment on the movie have a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of June and the cell will be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best
the block that everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition and you've been the
best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]